in this segment we derive and discuss
the Markov inequality a rather simple
but quite useful and powerful fact about
probability distributions the basic idea
behind the Markov inequality as well as
many other inequalities and bounds in
probability theory is the following we
may be interested in saying something
about the probability of an extreme
event by extreme event we mean that some
random variable takes a very large value
if we can calculate that probability
exactly then of course everything is
fine but suppose that we only have a
little bit of information about the
probability distribution at hand for
example suppose that we only know the
expected value associated with that
distribution can we say something well
here is a statement which is quite
intuitive if you have a non-negative
random variable and I tell you that the
average or the expected value is rather
small then there should be only a very
small probability that the random
variable takes a very large value this
is an intuitively plausible statements
and the Markov inequality makes that
statement precise here's what it says if
we have a random variable that's
non-negative and you take any positive
number the probability that the random
variable exceeds that particular number
is bounded by this ratio if the expected
value of X is very small then the
probability of exceeding that value of a
will also be small furthermore if a is
very large the probability of exceeding
that very large value drops down because
this ratio becomes smaller so that's
what the Markov inequality sells let us
now proceed with the derivation let's
start with the formula for the expected
value of x and just to keep the argument
concrete let us assume that the random
variable is continuous so that the
expected value is given by an integral
the argument would be exactly the same
as in the discrete case but in the
discrete case we would be using a sum
now since the random variable is
non-negative this integral only ranges
for
zero to infinity now we're interested
however in values of X larger than or
equal to a and that tempts us to
consider just the integral from a to
infinity over the same quantity how do
these two quantities compare to each
other since we're integrating a
non-negative quantity if we're
integrating over a smaller range the
resulting integral will be less than or
equal to this integral here so we get an
inequality that goes in this direction
now let us look at this integral here
over the range of integration that we're
considering X is at least as large as a
therefore the quantity that were
integrating from a to infinity is at
least as large as a times the density of
X and now we can take this a which is a
constant pull it outside the integral
and what we're left with is the integral
of the density from a to infinity which
is nothing but the probability that the
random variable takes a value larger
than or equal to a and now if you
compare the two sides of this inequality
that's exactly what the Markov
inequality is telling us now it is
instructive to go through a second
derivation of the Markov inequality this
derivation is essentially the same
conceptually as the one that we just
went through except that it is more
abstract and does not require us to
write down any explicit sums or
integrals here's how it goes
let us define a new random variable Y
which is equal to zero if the random
variable X happens to be less than a and
it is equal to a if X happens to be
larger than or equal to a how is Y
related to X if X takes a value less
than a it will still be a non-negative
value so X is going to be at least as
large as the value of 0 that Y takes if
X is larger than or equal to a y will be
a so X will again be at least as large
so no matter what we have the inequality
that y is always less than or equal to X
and since this is always the case this
means that the expected value of y will
be less than or equal to the expected
value of X but now what is the expected
value of y since Y is either 0 or a the
expected value is equal to a times the
probability of that event which is a
time's the probability that X is larger
than or equal to a and by comparing the
two sides of this inequality what we
have is exactly the Markov inequality
let us now go through some simple
examples suppose that X is exponentially
distributed with parameter equal to 1 so
that the expected value of X is also
going to be equal to 1 and in that case
we obtain a bound of 1 over a to put
this result in perspective note that we
are trying to bound a probability we
know that the probability lies between 0
& 1
there is a true value for this
probability and in this particular
example because we have an exponential
distribution this probability is equal
to e to the minus a the markov
inequality gives us a bound in this
instance the bound takes the form of 1
over a and then equality tells us that
the true value is somewhere to the left
of here a bound will be considered good
or strong or useful if that bound turns
out to be quite close to the correct
value so that it also serves as a fairly
accurate estimate unfortunately in this
example this is not the case because the
true value falls off exponentially with
a whereas the bound that we obtain falls
off at a much slower rate of 1 over
for this reason one would like to have
even better bounds than the mark of
inequality and this is one motivation
for the chebyshev inequality that we
will be considering next but before we
move there let us consider one more
example suppose that X is a uniform
random variable on the interval from
minus 4 to 4 and we are interested in
saying something about the probability
that X is larger than or equal to 3 so
we're interested in this event here so
the value of the density because we have
a range of length 8 the value of the
density is 1/8 so we know that this
probability has a true value of 1 over 8
which we can indicate on a diagram here
probabilities are between 0 & 1 we have
a true value of 1 over 8 let us see what
the Markov inequality is going to give
us there is one difficulty that X is not
a non-negative random variable so we
cannot apply the Markov inequality right
away
however the event that X is larger than
or equal to 3 is smaller than the event
that the absolute value of x is larger
than or equal to 3 that is we take this
blue event and we also add this green
event and we say that the probability of
the blue event is less than or equal to
the probability of the blue together
with the green event which is the event
that the absolute value of X is larger
than or equal to 3 so now we have a
random variable which is non-negative
and we can apply the markov inequality
and write that this is less than or
equal to the expected value of the
absolute value of X divided by 3 what is
the expectation of the absolute value of
x x is uniform on this range the
absolute value of x will be taking
values only between 0 & 4
and because the original distribution
was uniform the absolute value of X will
also be uniform on the range from zero
to four and for this reason the expected
value is going to be equal to two and we
get a bound of two thirds this is a
pretty bad bound it is true of course
but it is quite far from the true answer
could we improve this bound in this
particular example we can because of
symmetry we know that the probability of
being larger than or equal to three is
equal to the probability of being less
than or equal to minus three or the
probability of this event which is the
blue and the green is twice the
probability of just the blue event or to
put it differently this probability here
is equal to one-half of the probability
that the absolute value of x is larger
than or equal to three and therefore by
using the same bound as here we will
obtain an answer of one-third so by
being a little more clever and
exploiting the symmetry of this
distribution around zero we get somewhat
better bound of 1/3 which is again a
true bound it is more informative than
the original bound but still it is quite
far away from the true answer